[Musik]
es ist der tummelplatz der reichen und
schönen der schweizer ort st moritz im
herzen der alpen
hier trifft luxus auf internationalen
jetset doch auch ursprüngliches gibt es
zu sehen wie den sogenannten schiefen
turm der st mauritius kirche aus dem
zwölften jahrhundert und moderne akzente
wie dieses appartement haus entworfen
vom britischen stararchitekten norman
foster sankt moritz ist vor allem als
wintersportort bekannt aber urlauber
kommen noch im sommer auf ihre kosten
vor allem jene die eine sportliche
herausforderung suchen denn in den
warmen monaten werden sonst
schneebedeckten pisten zu wanderwegen
und mountainbike trails
[Musik]
das spiel war früher schweizer banker
und hat dann umgesattelt
heute führt er monaten bei thun in
seinen gruppen fahren menschen fast
jeden alters mit
es braucht allerdings schon ein bisschen
mut
[Musik]
es gibt ganz unterschiedliche trails
hiervon steinig für block schwierig bis
zu dem gebauten floß und die sind da
nicht für jedermann machbar aber man
muss mountainbiken können es reicht
nicht immer nur dass statt vater
geworden ist
also hätte man gewinnen ist natürlich
der wintersport immer noch king und der
sommer im sommer wird mountainbike immer
mehr zu queen
[Musik]
beliebt sind im sommer oft und
windsurfen wie auf dem silberplatz
sieben kilometer von st moritz und fern
können die chance ihre fähigkeiten
testen
[Musik]
alex premier hat seine französische
heimat vor elf jahren verlassen um ihr
als winzer auf lehrer zu arbeiten
nach seiner meinung sind die bedingungen
besser als irgendwo sonst
obwohl der wind heute mal nicht ganz so
stark bläst nicht so weit vom strom gibt
keine große welle der wind immer da
haben wir verschiedene ecken oder
windstärke und weniger stark so von
anfang an zum professioneller wenn wir
die beste verhältnis
[Musik]
eine typische schweizer spezialität ist
schokolade so wie hier in der confiserie
hanselmann mitten in der altstadt eines
der ältesten cafés und sein geriet schon
seit 1894 genia einheimische und
touristen ein und aus war das ganz
berühmt ist und viele gäste auch von
block kaufen das weil das ist die
spezialität von ganze regionen ganz so
mit schokolade wir haben die spezielle
pralinen da sind sie hier alles und wir
haben verschiedene sorten beruf die
haben sie ohne alkohol
oder haben sie mit alkohol und dann
verschiedene andere sorten das ist vom
geschmack her von kunden
[Musik]
wer den tag ganz entspannt ausklingen
lassen möchte kann sich ein bisschen
wellness in einem der luxushotels von
sankt moritz können gleich fünf davon
gibt es im umkreis von vier kilometern
im badrutt's palace hotel arbeitet
marinella negri seit fünf jahren im
smart bereich sie ist spezialistin für
ayurvedische massagen via bieten
verschiedene behandeln aber ich finde
vor allem ayurveda an dass es besonders
gut um den körper zu reinigen und zu
entgiften eine erfrischung für körper
und geist sind das klare wasser von
sankt moritz und die frische bergluft
allemal
und anders als die meisten dinge hier
gibt es diese aussicht sogar umsonst
[Musik]